Caroline had reached out to you in the
past how was she when you spoke to her
well this is what really upsets me
because I know how it feels to feel that
low and when someone reaches out to you
like that and I couldn't I'm not help to
enough because of idiotic people on
social media trying to get a headline
trying to get more followers I don't
think they understand the impact that
has on somebody's mental health it's so
so wrong on so many levels
and regardless Ages to each other I
don't know whether I did the right thing
in putting those on social media but I
do feel that her death cannot be in vain
and that we have to kind of stand
together and I had some show people what
it's like for people like myself and
Caroline in this industry when you make
a mistake and you're not even allowed to
try and fix that mistake in privacy I
know how it feels when you lose all your
contract and you know everyone turns
against you it's horrid
that me myself I'm a mother to five
mazing children and Caroline is a human
being who is allowed to make mistakes
with humans that is what we do we learn
from our mistakes but the fact that she
wasn't even allowed to even learn from
this whole situation
angers me so much and Kari if there was
to be one positive thing that would come
out of this heartbreaking tragedy what
would that be hopefully that social
media context some kind of
responsibility our messages that go out
there but press now I I use the press I
work with the press I'm sat here in
front of a camera now trying to promote
and highlights online bullying there's
an aspect to it where I'll do a photo
shoot advertising something so I also
work with the press so it is a push and
a pull kind of thing but is controlled
press that we need to bring in not just
assuming and selling stories and a
closer says this and a close if you are
these sources catch up with HP
I don't know who these sauces eat
ridiculous this it's all hearsay get
your facts right and realize the person
you're talking about is actually a human
being yeah okay karakurt's and I really
appreciate you talking to me under very
difficult circumstances thank you very
much for your time and it's worth saying
that we can't corroborate scary's claims
regarding father's for justice but we
will of course them look into that and
if you need to talk about how you're
feeling the Samaritans are there to talk
anytime they promise to listen in
confidence and without judgments you can
call them free on one one six one two
three or email Joe at Samaritans dot org